I'd worked on a play with Christopher
and Sam two or three years ago so it's
just like handing them the script and
calling them up and they said yes Colin
obviously from Bruges we said we wanted
to do something again as soon as we
finished doing that woody had known for
years Tom Waits I almost did a did
something in theatre with him so so
everyone was first choice Abby and Olga
similarly yeah I guess it's really all
of your seven first choice psychos if
you work with good actors you know they
care about good scripts they care about
nice dialogue and they don't want to
they don't want to come up with stuff
unless you know they need to what I've
learned is that from this process was
littered just getting off my high horse
a little bit and recognizing that as a
director whatever gets an actor into the
scene is and gets into the truth is seen
as equally valid
he says Sam for instance would always
improve your improv has a few lines just
before we set action and then he'd go
off and stick to the script
or he'd or in rehearsals he'd you know
improvise around and as would you know
the other guys but then some of that
lovely stuff would end up as being
usable and particularly the the end of
the cemetery shootout scene when the
boys are discussing how they feel about
the script players and moving and lots
of that was we just let the cameras
rolling lots of that was improvised we
would determined to make it here even
though they were telling us that tax
breaks and other things would make it
better to to not film it here which
would seem crazy because I do believe in
the town being a major character and in
you know you don't write it to be set
here and not think about those issues
similarly with Bruges you know it was
always gonna be if we weren't allowed to
make it in Bruges out of scrap the whole
thing I wouldn't have
put it in Vienna or elsewhere similarly
similarly with this it had to be it's a
you know it's a film belt in some ways
Hollywood so it have to be set here but
I want it to I guess explore some areas
of LA that hadn't maybe been been seen
before or for a few years I guess what
most of the characters in the film are
from the underbelly of or struggling you
know know what no one's really made it
so I wanted to explore where would those
characters live so we found places in
Silver Lake and Echo Park and and then
little spots around the Venice Beach
that I guess the Venice Beach stuff had
been film before but we found a perfect
little house there was kind of a crappy
and low-rent place but I had a curiously
had a beautiful Vista over downtown but
also Joshua Tree was always a major
element at the film too should be to set
the the beginning in a very urban almost
depressing gangster new year first time
I ever never used that word media and
but then go to a kind of almost Sergio
Leone like Vista which which the Joshua
Tree had some buckets but we only got to
actually film it for some reason the
national parks don't let you explode
cars and shoot each other in the park
itself so we had to film in some equally
beautiful spots outside of Lancaster and
Palmdale I tried to make my place as
cinematic as as I possibly could but but
you kind of know if it's a play if it's
more or less set in a room or a couple
of rooms and there are four or five
characters you know it's gonna be in in
that territory whereas the the landscape
of this and the city of Bruges made
these have to be films you can write the
kind of a character like hands and hope
that and he's got a lot of crazy stuff
to say and it's really off-the-wall
individual but
the humanity that comes across from
Christopher's performance particularly
is is nothing that you ever know you
know obviously from the script
you don't know where brilliant actors it
going to take your work so that is that
those aspects of it are always the most
joyous and life-affirming